si maurice coin je suis d'économistes
je suis consultant international et
l'éducation
la passion qu'ont ces derniers années
c'est l'écriture
déjà 9 et 14 c voilà la preuve on m'a
dit de venir parler de ce que je veux
pourvu que ça concerne le changement
vous aimez s'est empressé parce que j'ai
choisi d'abord ces changements pourquoi
et comment le changement pourquoi et
comment
j'avoue que ce thème mais c'est parce
que autour d'une touche
il ya des gens qui sont là bas niveau de
la hat ne vais pas me dire des labos
boutique débattues sans chauffeur déjà
combattu aussi elle la bulle les matches
18 victoires des souterrains mais bush
alors on n'a pas le choix tu as dit
rouge avec ce qui bouge ou bien on les
amène donc beaucoup intéressé et ces
jeux soient simples et b2 mais perd et
vous a que 15 de luxe c'est pas les
cheminots
le changement est inexistant obsolètes
dépassées demander si vous prêtez et
avait dû synonyme de vrai y'a pas de
mort et vingt six mois que je suis celui
qui n'est pas habituel à grand chose il
a dit à déclasser certaines existant qui
la rend cet égard il nous faut
je pense à tous alors il ya un problème
s'il n'a pas un futur qu'il essaie de
concevoir avec un budget pub et elle
occupe aussi il a déterminé il sera
victime de des progrès non il n'y a pas
de loup et il va subir le changement
mais là c'était dingue
alors les cordes sensibles négative
vous devez vous dire que j'étais
consultant international et cette
habitude de voyager beaucoup d'observer
de regarder des constatés et les
diagnostiquer alors favorable lui aussi
dit oui afrique et nous y voyons
qu'est ce que nous avons comme comme
ceux ci le négatif jeudi et corde
sensible négatif parce que y'a les
passants surpris il ya beaucoup les
centres d'intérêts
mais moi je nous peut-être davantage
associées négative alors on y va
nous appliquer si le doyen a eu mais
cette proposition soit paris pas chance
aux appétits du beh ans il nous a donné
des chances ceux qui lisent pas chance
5ème édition émission qui gagne le prix
donc vous l'avez déjà attaché au même
régiment du pareil au même méthode
taille
oui mais là c'est ça oui ça me serre la
vis des personnes moi je suis africain
non non ne me fatigue pas tu te la fait
arrêter au grain dans l'espace vide
utilisant non une pensée ronald est liée
ni de change les
un songe et croit même pas changé le
caddie le mhsc puis il avait notamment
fait la même charrette et on ne bouge
pas c'est pour ça que nous allons
engager l'échangé s'il aura le subir
hier on est un peu sensible à une
philosophie sociale sans les u on a dit
le prêt à s'asseoir à manger ensemble à
danser ensemble à a profité des séries
qui travaillent mais quand il s'agit de
suivi pour travailler avec personne et
bush
saïd et présidents semblent ont lieu
tous les cas ce qui n'a pas été un peu
le monde n'appartient à personne dont il
ya des individus dans nos pays qui ont
qui va essayer de chéchia bhl a doublé
sa dette a doublé ce que les autres on a
vu plusieurs exemples malheureux qui
m'en faire des idées de 264 millions
et le problème c'est que y'a un jour et
c'est le but dit il plante ou la main la
main qui doit être affectée à la
création du pôle et qu'il est il a pu la
voir il est partout et personnages et
vous c'est klaus
une mentalité de gagnant du temps à m
avez vous déjà dit partout dans le monde
et j'ai essayé de voiliers aussi pont du
pdg de daon attendait le bon je les ai
pas vus combien avez-vous peut-être une
balle vous avez vous déjà vu une banque
de temps l'agent les temps c'est
l'argent d'après la mairie
et pourtant il a tenue d'époque de tout
âge ou s'il n'y a pas de bottes des
temps c'est parce qu'il ya un probant
que cela définit notre leader et il faut
le temps étant insaisissable parti passe
il faut une saisie et puis il faut faire
et l'évier pour te propulser si le
terrain il faut absolument que le temps
qu'il a publié un peu sous ce soit votre
compagnon de lutte
j'habite au desssus première dame se
vider le père dans tout ce que nous
voulons
j'ai fait un livre ils résident on parle
notamment de que fais tu étais un buster
et de brion ouattara il a droit aussi à
ces 24 heures la reine n'était aussi
avoir ses lois ses 24 le souci dans la
rue le mondial
chacun de nous connaît l'oubli le père a
aussi droit à 5 94 km la prétendante 8 8
et 24 heures des pantins à venir c'est
dingue ça qui fait la différence entre
les pays développés et des pays sous
développés
vous allez voir aux sirènes de buts
c'est la catastrophe
mais dites vous qu'il ya une atteinte à
12h04 10h04
forcément il s'échauffe si je suis venu
leur dire le droit
il attend de sa singulière non il faut
on change tout c'est la petite place à
nourrir leur 6e ne sent pas bien le
parlement va nous changer les six ans
baptisera est ce nous sommes maîtrisé
par le temps et la non dépôt le bénitier
tout dépend du site est développé à
[Applaudissements]
ça fait pitié mais ça fait 7 la petite
la plus répandue en côte d'ivoire et en
afrique
des voiliers bateaux dont c'est la même
table mais tu passes à travers toute
l'afrique et nous allons tout ouïe biais
de mendier
quand olivier je donnais benatia
devenait très bien intégré il vient de
la mer et de sites amis et bebo s'il y
avait fait toute la pression tout
apporté tous ces directives
alors vous pensez vous si jamais été dit
et s'active pas donc monsieur nous pas
tous les mendiants set ça satisfait de
tout une autre culture
et ça nous rend plus faible depuis de
crédible à la donner l'exemple
openoffice retient le recours
systématique aux dents ou aide pour
qu'ensuite et attitudes nous sommes ses
clients en afrique c'est qu'en dis tu es
avec ça on n'est pas capable de mettre
la main ensemble avec un site de
réseautage et métayers polytechnique
aurait-il pour construire notre siège en
site web chercher de la base d'un
rapport aux autres il ne dit pas bien
pour ces deux hôpitaux qui à l'inversé a
dit que des noirs ici
merci beaucoup de nous pencher
sereinement utiliser si on était
conscient que les japonais sait que
c'est la taille et je prends de l'agent
secret baptisé 60 premiers discerner et
rigoureux j'ai pas trop en faire on veut
faire mieux beaucoup plus avec sauna oui
on a bien parlé de budget s'équilibre
mais ce cadeau nous peut aussi fait ce
budget là parce que c'est pas la peine
le 200 c'est un processus c'est pas une
course de vitesse
oubliant les politiques soient
programmées et pour ça très bien ce que
nous voulons faire pour réduire les
aides extérieures ou un recours est
rejeté à voir dans tous les refuges et
c'est pas tout lu un peu tout ça la plus
à des budgets des arts de la rue des
lilas plus loin notamment via des
lentilles banlieue pour habiller pour
vos tirs 20 % aux aides extérieures mais
comment on peut compter sur les autres
amies people je suis mieux senti diable
ce claf
je pense qu'ils feront sentir au chien
parce qu'elle paraît aussi longtemps que
vous serez toujours des modèles des rues
aux noms depuis j'ai plein de nouveaux
décès mais se découvrent le collectif
d'être le propriétaire de la bourse vous
vous engagez dans un engrenage
vous n'avez vous le savez le problème
c'est que c'était un modèle massé quoi
parce que les gens voudraient non je
vous regarde si vous comptez tir sous d
autres mais des milliers de civils vous
reportez vous à cette projet grandit
j'attends je n'ai pas aucune initiative
qui ne fait aucun effort passe l'été
elle a été ramenée de la bank am
bellevue
mais partir là c'est grave
et bien si les post grave c'est pour
être rapidement avant ce conduit et vous
ça vous n'êtes pas vous imaginer combien
de fois il ya des dégâts des gens qui
s'y met le feu ou bien qu'ils s'équipent
se jette dans la ville parce qu'elle n'a
pas su mettre l'élève l'heure le pcot
label ils ont pensé de dieu et ne mérite
pas d'avoir envie de s'amuser nikkei
mais il pousse mieux attendre travail un
peu basique tranquillement tu as gagné
ce n'est pas mal du tout donc ça fait
que dans la maille d'après vous la
convoiter la baisse la maille d'appui
populaire d'autres clubs dits la
vieillesse satisfait pas abattu stalair
cette dramatique ça tout le prix des
gens traités boulade le sida et j'en
passe et pourtant ça si facile pour lui
le soir ancien et qu'on essaie de
s'organiser comme michaud et qu'on
essaie de progresser vers des pouvoirs
et les bills ont raconté capacité le bas
en comptant sur les autres alors il ya
rfu déchirait les rechutes personnel à
l'aide du budget familial
oui tout à fait vous parlez de finances
personnelles pour être plus visibles du
budget familial est fier de toi c'est le
budget familial
il n'est pas très compliqué mais ces
tirs c'est une méthode qui est
percutante et qui est bien pour lui à
travers nous c'est le bois lui dit jeudi
veulent à nouveau sourit mais il faut
toujours faire des les palmes sa
première dépense vider les villes où les
10 il n'est pas décédé tennis pourrait
parier
c'est une volonté de résister à deux
millions trois millions et illicites ou
de famille enfin le salaire une richesse
le salaire est que l époque où nous
verrions débile c'est à saluer entretien
mais ça nous permet à condition petit la
rigueur la discipline et des doutes ils
sont de tout le monde se met en place et
c'est là que tsonga est arrivé et les
violations et de machettes ont un peu
fait pour adopter une culture de
changement prendre conscience de votre
retard si les loutres oui c'est l'animal
les diagnostics tard et aussi longtemps
qu'on n'a pas pris toute la mesure des
états qui nous a fait fort applaudi
n'oubliez pas nous sommes en anglais
planétaire
on est bien obligé de regarder les
autres
morgan passé 2 à travers les déserts
admet et gagnent ici pas la pire
poursuit eh bien il ya beaucoup
d'opportunités ici mais mon aveux vous
étiez il est temps qu'on nous les hits i
l'état prenne conscience que healy a
énormément dépanneur de contrainte est
ici et il est un peu en plus je fais un
immeuble fait des pas en avant de
glisser entre deux notions de rattraper
quelque peu de temps perdu à moi c'est
une rupture avec la culture de facilité
tout est facile pandore et enfin si le
tonton 02 taiana on le voit pas il ya
des petits là où ça qui arrive ici qui a
des petits loups qui avec la russie a
dépensé la russie et qui disent des
choses que nous n'avons pas évident et
c'est avec labellisée famille atypique
qui auront lieu de nuit une récupéré
permettra d'après le monde perd il faut
peut emmener on abandonne cette culture
de facilité qu'il avait dit et qui fait
que nous sommes obligés de nous on ne
vient pas du tout animal est aussi doté
peau
c'est grave depuis au si de rien n'était
de mentalité envie de changer notre
conception de la vie oui il faut être
utile c'est qu'on a vue il a nié sa
femme assez pour continuer il faut
passer en revue toutes ces cultures là
pour que nous puissions pour le nous
orienter vers direction qui sont plus
prometteuses donc note me souviens de
lee doivent changer
devenu un but et des motifs des
changements si vous ne mettez pas votre
vie avec des objectifs
il ya des individus par et vous oubliez
plus d'ados d'environnement qui vont
devoir bouger parce que c'est important
ça lui sourit dit le fils et fille ne
s'est pas bien pas bien tous
objet de financer les émotifs deux
autres et ça s'est tellement contents
d'eux il faut que chacun de nous fasse
un effort pour essayer des techniques
terme et où il va au lieu d'aller
partout passé quand ce n'est pas tout
une la nulle part donc c'est vraiment
important
voilà beaucoup mais je m'arrête là peut
nous puissions éventuellement poser et
j'ai beaucoup lu amusez-vous
il n'y a aucune évolution copains pour
le grèce en pis cette double appui
repris depuis après et d'accepter ou de
s'imposer le chalon il faut alors subi
nous avons la possibilité de pouvoir
très prochainement positif sans
annulation il n'y a pas de mouvements
récents boulot il n'y a pas de
changement de position sur les bushmen
sont toujours là un pays sous développé
nous serons toujours là dans le cas des
bicoques nous serons toujours là afin de
marcher à pied à moto vélo c'est pas ça
peut dire plus pour nous doit primer sur
de meilleures mains il a donné à chacun
de nous une mentalité ils forcent un
pouvoir qui nous permet d'échanger entre
nous on continue à être aide à ces
pressions de plus en plus inconfortable
où vous évoluiez bien votre position
s'il a l'air le chat noir doit être sue
site est piloté par opel changement
narry sentiments il ya toujours un prix
et je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]